Selinda freed who is the Dean of the
mailman School of Public Health and
school of public health is one of the if
not the leader at Columbia University in
taking on global questions both at a
scholarly level but also at a very very
practical level and so she is deeply
engaged in that enterprise as Dean but
her particular field of expertise is
also highly relevant to the discussion
of this colloquium so this colloquium is
about the problem of the youth bulge and
Linda Freed's expertise one of the
leaders in in the world on this issue is
about the elderly bulge and it seemed
like a very good complement to the
discussion today to think about at least
a little in the context of the youth
bulge what is the role what are the
consequences of the fact that many
societies have a great elderly
population and aging population so
School of Public Health has 300 faculty
it works in over a hundred countries it
is it is really a powerhouse and and
something that we're very very proud of
Linda is a just wonderfully imaginative
mind and she's been working with Mark
Wiggly dean of the school of
architecture urban planning with Carol
Becker the Dean of the School of the
Arts some faculty in the School of
Engineering and Applied Science to think
about issues like how should cities be
designed given a growing population
elderly people but the interesting part
for us is that the link is to younger
people as well if you want to help
younger people do something for your
elderly population because that will
actually produce the benefits that you
that you want so it's that kind of
enterprising work here that we admire so
much and thought we would have you share
in so Linda please come up
well good afternoon it takes a very
imaginative mind to to to have someone
lead an entire meeting discussing the
youth bulge and ask someone to come and
talk about old people solely thank you
but with my broader cap on then perhaps
the discussion of older people I have to
say that the focus of this meeting I
think is is on a preeminent concern for
all of us the youth bulge in developing
countries and how to ensure benefiting
from the demographic dividend the
opportunity for this will close for most
countries by mid century now I've been
asked to talk about the seemingly
diversionary and generally proceeded to
be competitive issue of aging and old
people while you're focusing on youth so
to tell you my punchlines first at least
so you know where I'm going to go here
I'd like to ask you to consider how
longer lives in this century in this
century will require new curricula and
new educational approaches for our
current students and then whether older
people could provide some now hidden
solutions for our youth and
accomplishing the benefits of the
demographic dividend I've had the great
honor of reading the really incisive
summaries that the university presidents
here provided on the issues that needs
the opportunities and the challenges
regarding the youth bulge in so many
countries defining this of course as the
populations in which use 15 to 24
constitute twenty percent or more of the
population the points raised very
a lot across countries and contexts and
needs and yet there are a number of
shared concerns that were raised across
these reports including that too often
young people are not getting a high
quality education that the health
behaviors of our young people are poor
or even dangerous that dropout rates are
high that access is too limited and yet
their university education zahra
marketable that they're unemployed in
large numbers that more vocational and
practical training is needed that
assistance with learning workplace
skills as needed and that massive
migration to cities leads to larger
numbers seeking jobs then cities are
prepared to handle you've also offered
many best practices and potential
solutions that you're additionally
considering but a number of the reports
brought out to me clear statements of
alarm and I'll quote one which said we
are wasting our demographic dividend the
opportunity of course which is created
when a large emerging workforce that is
also well educated and skilled and
prepared to be productive could be the
economic engine for future prosperity
now as president Bollinger mentioned
interestingly many countries are
experiencing an elder bulge as well as a
youth bulge let's consider the data if
you look demographically there are three
main patterns youth bulge post youth
bulge and going towards a youth deficit
and youth deficit the latter two types
of countries approach having an approach
having an equal number and for some many
times more older adults respectively
than youth and this ratio of old to
young is going to progressively increase
through mid century this is a result of
course of both decreasing numbers of
children per family in many con
trees although not all while life
expectancy has been increasing
dramatically yet silently global life
expectancy has increased from 47 years
to almost 70 years since 1950 in many
countries these older adults people now
living longer lives are the best
educated and healthiest older adults in
the history of the world in countries
particularly affected by the AIDS
epidemic life expectancy of course has
been grievously lower than was otherwise
anticipated but for those who are HIV
negative in those countries life
expectancy is increasing life expectancy
will continue to increase through mid
century this is an amazing success of
human history absolutely unprecedented
so contrary to many people's perceptions
the developing countries that have a
youth bulge are also doubling or
tripling the number of older adults and
we'll have an elder bulge in 10 to 50
years overall all countries will move
towards an equal number of children and
older adults in society across the
century so today I have a habit of
showing up I guess and offering a
counterintuitive position but this tie
was asked I didn't offer and so having
been asked I would like to consider with
you the relevance of aging and longer
lives to our youth and to their
educational needs this could be a
distraction it could be even an
unhealthy diversion more older people
are the issue of more older people
around is often perceived as a looming
demographic problem that will make
matters worse for our younger people if
we have to choose between investing in
our young people and our old people
however interestingly the Madrid
declaration of 2002 declared the
developing countries that ignore the
increasing aging population put their
development agenda at risk
and they further stated that age when
aging is embraced as an achievement the
reliance on human skills experiences and
resources of the higher age groups is
naturally recognized as an asset in the
growth of mature fully integrated and
humane societies so consistent with
perhaps the frame of the Madrid dacula
declaration there are two large
questions that I'd like to think about
with you and I'd like to probably have
the gall to offer a few proposals so the
first question is are there new
educational needs in societies where
people will be living longer lives as I
said we're entering an unprecedented
stage of human history which we don't
know how to do and we're not prepared
for we're living longer than we used to
life expectancy as i said is increasing
globally on every continent and as a
result developing countries for example
are going to age as a population in the
next 30 to 40 years to the degree that
developed countries took a hundred years
to achieve the young population now in
the youth bulge will turn 60 as members
of an old society with as many or more
older adults than children this
unprecedented distribution of ages is
going to require a lot of preparation
and many transitions to accomplish a
society of long lives which is good for
every age group these transitions for
ten many changes that universities I
think we'll need to consider and likely
transform themselves around this fact of
longer lives consider for example put
yourself in the mind of one of your
students 20 years old how will the fact
that they have a life expectancy of 70
or 80 years affect their view and goals
for their life compared to if life
expectancy was thirty-five or forty
seven and then what will our students
who will be leading still in 2050 need
to learn now to position them for that
those in the youth bulge may have 50 or
60 more years of life once they complete
their formal education if employed
they're going to have four to five
careers retirement ages when they exist
will get pushed back and they'll work
longer there will be changing job
demands over the next half century
sequential jobs and evolving personal
goals which as has been mentioned many
times today are going to require
lifelong learning even now many older
adults certainly in developed countries
are seeking opportunities for continued
learning becoming part of universities
during the third of their life after
retirement additionally types of jobs or
may expand just because there are more
older people more caregiving more health
care needs technology applied to helping
older adults stay independent etc and
further our youths are going to be
living in an intergenerational world and
they're going to need skills as to how
to work with older people work in teams
across generations all of this is going
to require dramatic changes in curricula
and approaches for education as well as
perhaps theories of education in
addition to put my public health hat on
here for a second the health of today's
youth across adulthood what they're
setting the stage for now will play out
through their entire adulthood in terms
of their health their productivity their
ability to work as well as societies and
their health care and social protection
needs and costs universities I think
need to consider how not to take for
granted that you understand how to
protect health we need curricula than
ensure our youth understand the
importance of Health and how to stay
healthy now and for their longer lives
so how will we give them the knowledge
and conditions now to support healthier
behave
years and to support their raising of
healthier children in just a few years I
leave those questions to you and go on
to the second question the second
question I would like to propose is
probably a little more out in left field
can an already aging population provide
some of the solutions for educating our
youth now so the country's get the
economic benefit of the demographic
dividend this question suggests I think
considering whether there is any value
in thinking about our two problems
quote-unquote youth the youth bulge and
the elder bulge together jointly and
whether some opportunities might become
apparent from the joint thinking so I'm
going to give you tell you one summary
and three stories and see if we can put
them together one evaluation of
prevention programs for adolescents at
risk which was by joy Dreyfus contends
that multiple approaches are needed for
youth success particularly taking on the
examples of preventing school failure
delinquency substance abuse and teen
pregnancy and the conclusions of course
not a surprise to anyone in this room
are that you have to have a mixture of
child and family interventions you have
to have a mixture of school-based
interventions and you have to have
community-based programs and they go
across every age group of youth
development and the most successful
community-based programs combined
individual attention to high-risk youth
with broad community-wide interventions
joy Dreyfus particularly pointed out
that in many successful programs
high-risk adolescents are attached to a
responsible adult who pays attention to
the young person specific needs and
older adults can be those responsible
adults one summary one story South
Africa conduct
an important pension experiment in the
early 1990s some rural townships receive
pensions and outcomes were compared by
Esther Duflo and her colleagues to the
two other townships which did not
receive them the results showed that in
the households of the grandmothers
getting a pension their granddaughters
were taller and weighed more and the
health and nutrition of these girls was
better overall thus cash transfers to
older women led to a sizeable effect on
child health second story this one I
know a fair amount about personally and
it's the story of experience score over
20 years ago I began and then completed
the design of a program with my
colleague mark Freedman to try and see
if we could develop new social
institution to harness the social
capital of older adults on behalf of
children's school success while say this
program was simultaneously designed by
us to be a health promotion program for
the older adults participating in this
the program is now in 23 US cities 20
years later focusing on ensuring the
success by third grade of children and
public elementary schools in settings
where social capital is too limited to
help the kids succeed the evaluation
results for our citywide implementation
in Baltimore Maryland will be reported
later this year but in the meantime
preliminary results are very optimistic
suggesting that placing a critical mass
of older people trained volunteers in an
elementary school enough according the
principal to support the success of all
children in each grade led to children
stopping acting out negatively because
they had the support of an older adult
and they weren't getting left behind
that misbehavior dropped by thirty to
fifty percent learning readiness
improved and standardized test scores
improved as did the school climate and
teacher retention at the same time early
results for the volunteers show greatly
increased satisfy
action that they are making a difference
in the world and improvements as well in
a variety of metrics of health and
function I'm not suggesting this as
universal application but the impact
that's having in the u.s. may suggest
some generalizability the final story
within the Uganda rural development and
training program in rural kabale
district they have developed a bottom-up
approach to integrated rural development
over the past 25 years their programs
are designed as Kofi Annan said in 1998
to fix the glaring mismatch of a massive
educated young people who cannot find
jobs in the cities and who are unwilling
to go back to the rural areas from which
they came you r dt is focused on
building community development and now
capacity and their programs include a
girls school with pre free primary and
secondary education a vocational skills
institute that develops mid-level
skilled trades people who create small
businesses and since 2006 the african
rural university for women with a 3 year
bachelor's degree in integrated rural
development leadership for our perp all
these programs are designed to support
retention of young people in this rural
region and to create a future integrated
with older generations for our purposes
I'll just mention one story from the
vocational skills institute the teachers
of the vocational training are often
older adults in the community master
craftspeople master builders and farmers
the they support local students but in
addition recently 200 teenagers from
kampala 180 miles away participated in
their youth leadership program funded by
the government the students were
unemployed or underemployed young men
and women who don't have vocational or
business skills this three-month program
taught them very practical skills in
making products like pens and baking
bread and fixing cars and in writing
business plans and managing businesses
so they can be job creators
many of the teachers were older adults
most of the students after completing
the program have not gone back to the
city but are instead returning to the
rural villages they originally came from
now that they know how to start their
own businesses and use these businesses
combined with basic farming to provide
enough income so in summary these these
examples I think suggest some real
potential and many possible positive
consequences for youth of different ages
and for older adults and for society in
putting oldandyoung together in the
right kinds of social institutions one
of the rate-limiting steps and scaling
up these kinds of approaches to
harnessing the social capital of an
aging society by putting both ends of
the demographic spectrum together is
that it can only happen if those in the
middle make it happen experiments like
the ones I just told you shift
assumptions and refill opportunity they
suggest that the world is leaving a lot
of resources on the table if you will
that we may not be able to afford to
ignore professor stiglitz said this
morning that the response to the youth
bulge has to be an increase in education
but that will require both resources and
social capital evidence to date
indicates that as people get older they
develop attributes that might actually
be useful for the problems we've been
discussing all day a lifetime of
knowledge and expertise the best rolodex
is around but also patience and
tolerance for complex even systems
problems and ability to solve them
seasoned with a critical dose of
generativity meaning wanting to make a
difference for those younger and wanting
to ensure that the world is left better
than one found it we have a tremendous
trust fund of older people in this world
they're already raising the orphans of
HIV serving as trustees of culture and
values and work in the full
at the roles in the world from farmers
to master craftsmen to heads of the UN
the World Economic Forum and
universities so now can we find new
roles for which they could be trained
and deployed to bring social capital to
those in the youth bulge there could be
lots of roles role models for successful
longer lives vocational or technical
training training the teachers to
improve the quality of education
teaching in new roles mentoring to
prevent dropout I could go on and on
with the right social institutions these
this social capital could be deployed to
high effect so in conclusion I'd like to
posit that older adults of the world's
only increasing natural resource period
the youth bulge will pass they offer
significant untapped social capital and
they would suggest that consistent with
the theme today that attending to the
needs of youth and societies tremendous
need for them to be to step into
productive roles requires leveraging
every strength and resource no one
resource is sufficient but all are
needed and I think we can't afford to
ignore what older adults could offer but
we have to have new social institutions
that could leverage it now it's for this
global coalition colloquium of
university presidents to continue the
proposal consider the proposal for max
price that there should be a global fund
for education but if positively received
or separately considered I would suggest
that we also need to think about a
global institution for social capital
bringing the social capital of older
adults to support our youth globally
both will be needed to meet the
challenges of rapid scale-up of
education provision and older adults
could serve both within and across
countries in person online in blended
models with with work with middle-aged
people bringing combinations of skills
expertise and desire to bear last few
points our youth bulge now are the older
adults forty years from now we need to
prepare them to be healthy and
productive through their young longer
lives and it is critical for them but
it's also critical for society we also
need to get ready to educate adults
throughout the life course the
approaches that I've mentioned today I
think could help prepare all countries
to become the aging societies we all
will be within the next 50 years laying
the basis for the social institutions
that will be needed when these same
youth are older adults in 2050 to as I
said to accomplish this vision for of a
joint future a joint future for young
and old will require by in leadership
and action by those of us in between a
successful and resilient society is one
that is respectful of and benefits from
the contributions of people of different
ages that thrives due to transfers
between generations and cohesion across
generations and lifts up those in need
the Secretary General said last night
that youth is a time for idealism and
that idealism is a state of mind one
aspect I have learned of getting older
is I think a Riemann sum that state of
mind but with many new layers of
perspectives about how to make it happen
older adults in my experience generally
want to make a difference creating new
social institutions that harness this
untapped social capital of older adults
into impactful solutions for the needs
of the youth bulge could be one of many
approaches needed to leverage the
demographic dividend and to strengthen
simultaneously societal resilience
for the long haul now I leave you with
referring to the title I concocted for
this talk which was a bit of a stretch
but it's a quote from Bob Dylan song
forever young which has two phrases that
Jermaine perhaps to our discussion he
said may you always do for others and
let others do for you may your hands
always be busy may your feet always be
Swift may you have a strong foundation
when the winds of change is shift may
you stay forever young our colleagues
from Mexico said in the report that we
are wasting our demographic dividend
that could be considered a societal
state of emergency in the face of
statements like that I think we cannot
afford to leave any social capital on
the table have to if I can mix metaphors
bring all hands on deck and create the
potential to do that so we can sail in
the right direction and reach Shore
successfully thank you
please join me in thanking the afraid
for that wonderful address president
Bollinger has been called out for just a
moment so he asked me to step up here
and moderate the questions you might
have for her so the floor is open for
anyone who had cared to pose any
questions I think the message we draw
from this is about the idea of a win-win
society where the youth and the elderly
have to work together and if they fail
to do so both will suffer and I think
that's a very important message for us
here when we're focused on the youth
bulge so I'd welcome any questions that
might be hosed what while I'm up please
one thing you didn't mention was
international migration where young
people are going to be drawn from young
countries to older countries and there's
great things in that one thing that you
worry about is that the countries that
are investing in the education of young
people may not realize the benefits if
people move so can you talk a little bit
about the dynamics of international
migration how you think it fits into
this young old picture that you painted
so nicely mixed Wow well I think there
was very serious discussion in the
present session this morning on the on
the very serious implications of the
brain during and it's probably beyond my
expertise to to understand how to
approach that but I think it needs to be
approached and there were a number of I
think important suggestions on a table
about exactly as you're saying how
critical it is to solve I guess the
proposal that that I was implicitly
saying and in my comments were that are
there ways
in some small way to create a reverse
brain during our their global approaches
that we could organize to take the
social capital of youth deficit
countries and of older adults in use
deficit countries and bring it to bear
even in the short term to help solve
some of the social capital deficits in
youth bulge countries when I don't know
if that would go anywhere toward
achieving parity I doubt it in terms of
the consequences of the brain drain but
it might actually bring social capital
to bear at the right moment at the right
time in the right situation thank you
yes please Linda thank you very much for
that so earlier today just stiglitz said
what a number of members of the global
colloquium have also said that their
concern one of their concerns is equity
and i would ask you as someone who's
devoted your career so admirably to
helping older people when you look at
some of our countries where there is a
issue of not just having as michael put
it win-win but a question of our old
people asking for more than their fair
share sometimes it would be wonderful if
someone who's devoted her whole career
to champion aging well and if if you
could say something of where you think
old people should be or older people I
put myself it should be willing to give
some to younger people too so they can
have more of a say in their lives I'd be
really interested this is an invitation
to you just to address the equity issue
which so many young p
full in our universities looking at the
older generation say you created all
these problems for us and now you're
telling us you're going to solve them
when you have it you've created the
problems so it's just a really open
invitation as someone who has standing
in you know in this area to say
something about the equity issue so the
equity issue is critical there's no
question i think the the challenge is
how to make sure that we think about it
in a factual way so so for example there
are many perceptions that jobs held by
old people are blocking the opportunity
for jobs for young people but while i
wouldn't claim to be an expert in this
area the the literature that i read
about that suggests that that actually
is a myth that is not supported by
reality it's our fears so I I say that
to say we need to make sure we
understand where the blockages to equity
truly are because sometimes they're not
what we perceive I also think that
models I don't mean to be self
referential but it's the only model I
can think of in my head at the moment
models like experience who are all about
turning the social capital of older
people when they are in a position to do
it to ensure that our children are
succeeding I think we could create a
million new kinds of roles that older
adults would leap to whether it's
retired professors or senior professors
or even university presidents tackling
the issues of how to create equity in a
new kind of society when we're lifespan
is so long and we have needs at all ends
those are those are empirical questions
which I don't think we know the answer
to
i but i do think that many of our
assumptions are not factually based when
we when we look into it the other thing
is you know we we need each other I mean
we can't just have everybody over the
age of 30 to drop out and let the young
people take over they need the senior
people around to so how to craft a
society that not just creates
opportunity but helps the youth step up
to it is also an approach to equity we
are we are in the verge of so many kinds
of change a head of us that we don't
have blueprints on more than we we do in
my head and how you have to be part of
the solution but I think there are ways
in which the creativity of seeing your
minds could maybe crack the case as well
Linda maybe I could ask you a last
question in Lee's introduction he
mentioned your interest in how cities
should be designed to be friendly for
the elderly I think it's an interesting
question in the sense that if i look at
american let's save in the broader sense
architecture and urban planning so much
of it in the post-war period seemed
design for the the newly middle-aged
families in suburbs and not so friendly
to either the youth or the elderly so my
question is do you is there a solution
that might also combine the interest of
the elderly and the young and rethinking
what spaces are best geared toward
experiencing the fullness livelihoods
that they can so I'll make a comment and
then I'll maybe invite my fellow deans
who have been thinking about this with
me to add to that if you would like but
interestingly thinking about how to
design environments to keep people
active healthy engaged
if you if you take the the needs of
older people at it turns out that if I
think if you designed a city to support
the needs of older people and of
children together you'd have a city that
worked even better for everybody even
better and it I can make the same
statement about health systems actually
if you're designed it for the four old
people you'd end up with a health system
that actually created health for
everybody cost-effectively so as a
design principle if you if your design
for the most vulnerable it's
user-friendly for everyone it might
actually look nicer to I I'll defer to
my colleagues if they want to have the
last word here mark or funny or Jeanette
or anybody since we've been thinking
about this right back now just to agree
with Linda and confirmed that the point
of your question I think the American
city both in its hyper dance form and
and in what is arguably America's worst
export the suburbs is enormously age
segregated it's arguably the most eggs
age segregated urbanism in the world but
the good news is America and probably
Western Europe will play almost no role
in the future of the city so the fact
that America is an appalling example in
this moment really doesn't matter
because America is not facing the
demographic tsunami that will lead to
the invention of these new societies and
new cities so there will be a moment
where America will learn lessons from
the Middle East from Africa from South
Asia South America and so on and and
will then rebuild itself because of
surely these other parts of the world
have the same experimental and even
utopian position that America once held
and almost certainly have the
nomic position that America once held so
I think first of your diagnosis is
correct the patient is not in very good
shape but actually that particular
patient is not that important
I think to add to what link that mark
says item from the engineering
perspective and technology perspective
we have to think that in these cities we
are looking at transgenerational
habitats in which we really have to
understand the mixture that we have and
how we actually provide the resources
and the support that all these
generations from kids to older adults
will have hiding is very important when
Linda said from a design perspective
designing for the most disadvantaged of
vulnerable actually we will make it best
for all thank you very much for those
robbers and please join me in thanking
Dean free for those inspirational
remarks of yours